the attacks took place in the heart of
vienna
just hours before austria entered a new
coronavirus lockdown
a cctv camera caught images of a heavily
armed attacker
looking for victims in the cobbled
streets of the city center
seconds later he shot this man at close
range
upon hearing some shots downstairs i
looked down the window
and i saw the attacker
running into various bars and
restaurants which
are lined up on our street
and people running away and this
one or two attackers i'm chasing them
all over the street that's all i saw
suddenly the shooting started at first
we didn't know what it was
but suddenly people in the neighbouring
gardens started to run
we stayed standing there and there was
shooting again closer
so we started to run away because we
didn't know if we were running in the
right direction
we ran into a hotel and hid there
four victims have been so far confirmed
dead but more than a dozen have been
injured
seven of them critically wounded one
armed attacker was killed by
police he's a 20 year old man with a
dual citizenship of both
austria and north macedonia he's been
named in the media as
curtin s and it's now known that he
served a prison term last year
for attempting to travel to syria and
join the islamic state group
two arrests have been made in the
austrian town of saint paulton
a city 35 miles west of vienna and a
manhunt is ongoing
it has now been confirmed that
yesterday's attack was clearly an
islamist terrorist attack
it was an attack out of hatred out of
hatred for our fundamental values
out of hatred for our way of life out of
hatred for our democracy
where all people are equal in rights and
dignity last night will therefore go
down in history as a night in which some
of our fellow human beings fell victim
to an attack which in reality
was aimed at all of us an attack on our
free society
but one thing is clear we will not be
intimidated by the terrorists
in the wake of the shootings germany
stepped up checks at the austrian border
as chancellor angela merkel expressed
solidarity
and coming less than a week since an
attack in the french city of nice
president emmanuel macron tweeted we
french share the shock and sorrow
of the austrian people
well france of course had already been
on high alert after the attacks there in
recent weeks
this attack here in vienna sharing some
of the hallmarks
of the shootings in paris five years ago
that killed so many people with
with multiple gunmen hunting victims on
the street shooting people
enjoying a night out and indeed leaders
in the rest of europe
now say they're stepping up vigilance to
prevent potential copycat
attacks potential more potential planned
attacks
like this one in the austrian capital
last night
paul reese there on the ground for us in
the austrian capital vienna thanks so
much paul